con mucha música y la reclamación de un
aborto libre y gratuito por bandera
miles de argentinas salieron a las
calles de buenos aires para intentar
hacer fuerza para que se legalice este
derecho en su país estas mujeres tienen
la esperanza de que el congreso
argentino apruebe una ley que permita
interrumpir el embarazo antes de la
semana 14
9 que es estrictamente en donde los
diputados van a decir que le iba a pasar
el recinto
de puerta
pero como decimos tenemos
con toda la madera
en la iniciativa fracaso por muy poco en
2018 pero ahora con alberto fernández en
el poder tienen la confianza de que este
diciembre obtendrán tras años de lucha
en favor del aborto un resultado el
proyecto de ley de 2020 obligará a
centros públicos y privados a realizar
el aborto aunque se admite la objeción
de conciencia' pero la división del país
sigue siendo muy grande hace unos días
miles de personas contrarias al aborto
también mostraron fuerza en las calles
ellos se quejan de que esto ya fue
rechazado hace dos años y creen que no
se debe debatir de nuevo a recopilar lo
que la indignación de tanta gente que ya
pasó por este debate del 2018 hace
apenas dos años cuando el congreso sea
laudo este tema y dijo no al aborto
de salir adelante argentina se
convertiría en el tercer país
latinoamericano en tener un aborto
totalmente libre sumándose a cuba y
uruguay